Why do we care about missing data?
Let's talk through a couple of points
as to why we should care about missing
data before we complete
an analysis using that data.
One of the more basic reasons
we might care about missing data
is that some statistical
algorithms just won't work,
if there are values
missing from the data.
Obviously, we can't move
forward with an analysis
if the process we're using
won't get us to the end result.
So in those cases, we just have
to deal with the missing data.
A second, more subtle reason is that
missing items can add BIAS to a model.
Now, the term BIAS in statistics refers
to the tendency of an analysis to
either over or under estimate the values
of that specific field or parameter.
In other words, if BIAS is present, it
could push the model results higher or
lower, depending on how much BIAS there
is in one of the variables we're using.
For example,
in our hypothetical survey where one
of the questions is related to age.
Many older respondents might
be hesitant to give their age.
And if we could actually know what
the real ages of the respondents are,
then we would have a more accurate
picture and one of the facts we would
find is that the average age of
the respondents is really 44.5.
But without the real data there, we
would be working with an average age of
40, depending what our business question
and analysis was trying to solve.
We would be creating downward BIAS.
That is BIAS towards a younger
demographic in our analytic model.
This could effect our results.
And more importantly,
the business decisions could be
made on inaccurate modeling.
As a side note if you'd like more
information on the various ways
a model process can be affected by BIAS,
take a look at these links.